you're on the cover of shape magazine
and not to put you down charlie I liked
your magazine cut mean it's no silly
style but yeah I think you look amazing
too and look at this outfit that you are
wearing there is this your is this your
work outfit every day every day what you
wear
no actually it's kind of funny I saw it
it was like I actually wasn't wearing
that I was wearing a yellow bikini so
they changed it to make it look a little
racier I guess oh I thought you were
just wearing a completely different
outfit it's amazing the things they do
will you look absolutely incredible the
dancing everyone says dancing there's
nothing there's nothing better for your
body than dancing yeah I mean you see
people on dancing the Stars obviously
they lose a bunch of weight and get in
shape and all that but I think it goes
is that further than that I think it
just makes you feel good and when you
feel good you just don't know you just
you just have a better day and you're
physical like you don't have to actually
dance but your physical how do you know
I'm physical because when you talk you
do this you know no that's that's called
desperate I do this a lot when I want
fire do well thank you for saying that
you know it's must be interesting
because you and and your brother Derek
are both famous for dancing and for
being great dancers and I'm thinking if
the two of you go to an event together
does everyone just clear a path I'm at
I'm picturing you two walking into a
bank together and people getting out of
the way and clapping yeah yeah you have
to dance at events uh we don't have to
but it sometimes happens mm-hmm it
happens all the time
uh yeah like we were actually just over
at a friend's house last week and and
yeah it was a game night we're playing
mafia and like charades and how you do
and then of course we pull up the the
carpet and just start dancing and that's
like Derek's go-to move he just is like
okay this is what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
bring the ladies and we're gonna dance
and so he does that and then then I get
jealous and I have to join it so yeah so
it becomes like a full-on dance party
your life is the opposite of mine I
don't do
at no event am i trying to dance or get
people to dance I mean it definitely
helps with some liquid courage we'll
just put it that way I have like stages
let's just put it that way we're like
I'm like nice and funny and happy and
giddy that's like first stage one oh if
you're drinking it yeah yeah yeah and
then second stage is like I just become
really bossy and like I make people do
things and then the third stage is like
I don't know I kind of get like really I
get birthday face birthday face it's
kind of like when you when it's kind of
like a sexy angry face and like right
now let me see that
you're like really into it but you kind
of look mad at the same time that's your
third face my third phase is crying yeah
stages crying oh then it's time to go
home okay my first stage is crying - I
Tragically because I'm so busy with this
show I cannot be a contestant on Dancing
with the Stars and we've heard the
audience gasp in horror but that's not
gonna happen
how do you assess me yeah yeah how do
you think I would do on that I think
you'd do good actually like we you
wouldn't you were introducing you kind
of did this when you said Julianne Hough
and you still you started doing this but
it was a little bit like one-sided so
you kind of actually have to like do it
like this so I would that would be my
only tip okay like you were kind of
doing like same arm and leg but it was
good okay I first of all I have no men I
have no memory of that part of the show
I'm erasing parts of the show in my mind
as I go so I don't know what movements I
make I move around a lot but I think I'd
be an amazing dancer if I put just a
little bit of time into it and by when I
see them when I say a little bit of time
I mean like years and you know what my
favorite people to dance with are people
actually they can't really dance then
they're just fun dancers so I why did
you say that what did you say I just
established that I'm a very good dancer
and would be then you said that's great
I'd love to dance with you because I
love people that don't dance at all and
are crappy at it that's kind of I know
we worried you worry about hurting
people's feelings or no no I do and it's
hard cuz you know you have like 30
seconds but really it feels like ten
seconds really it feels like five
seconds but you're trying to give them a
nice you know critique and then they're
telling you to wrap it up so then you
don't get to explain why you're giving
them that critique and then you just
look like a really mean person and I'm
not really mean I'm probably right but
it's tough it's tough you've got to give
that criticism on the air and you've got
to say I mean on this show we don't have
to Kurtis we criticize people but not to
their face yeah we tell jokes about
people who aren't here
if they ever come by Andy and I just run
away and hi no I can't hide I'm there
you